if you are looking for aggressive and a
tricky line against the London system
then congratulations to clicking this
video as if you manage to watch until
the end you are going to equip with a
lifetime solution to lock the London
Tower
[Music]
after D4 I propose you should start with
Knight to F6 and there are two ways
white can enter into the London system
and amongst them if we continue with
Knight to F3 then I propose you should
respond with D5 and in my chest trap 17
I have shown the whole rapruta how to
handle this line effectively
however by far the most popular choice
is Bishop to F4 where white is remain
flexible
and this time around we are going to
respond with C5
and after this
against all of five major Alternatives
by white
black is simply well prepared
so let's see each by Tone and find out
how we are going to tackle them
starting from the bottom let's start
with Knight to F3
and I think this is one of the easiest
move as black and simply capture on D4
setting up a small trap that if white
continue with Knight captures D4 then he
instantly lose the piece with E5 as the
simple tactical point is Bishop takes E5
runs into this queen chat where black
napped the whole piece
so nope white can't play Knight takes D4
here that means he has to play Queen
captures D4
and after this even though Knight C6
looks very logical here I propose this
nice move D6 where black threat is very
obvious E5 and nabbing the piece one
more time
and the screen checks are always useless
because it just help black to develop
the pieces
so by far white has chosen the move
Queen to D1
but this makes black life very easy with
Queen to P6
okay white has two options and amongst
them if you continue with Queen to C1
then after E5 Bishop to E3 and queen to
C7 we have a very easy notched off
Sicilian kind of setup whereas I have
highlighted over here
black has a very simple piece layout and
don't forget white has completely jammed
up his e-pawn so he's not controlling
the center and his pieces are not
ideally placed
if you look at the engine evaluation
here it is already given -1 to Black
which is close to upon advantage
the second option B3 has been highestly
choose here
but I'm afraid this severely weaken the
dark squares and we will jump on it
immediately with Knight to E4
setting up a small trap that if white
continue with the most natural move E3
then he can lose the game instantly with
this nice move
yup G5
what a move
well white has three choices and amongst
them once again capturing on gifa is a
pretty bad idea as after the end of the
sequence Knight takes Bishop takes and
this queen check nabbed the piece
so capturing the gifa is right out of
the equation
how about countering this Knight with
Bishop to D3
well this time around even worse news
for white as black has this little
sacrifice on F2 which completely
Bamboozled the white Cam
the point is
what has to take this night and after
that when we recapture the piece
white epon Spin and with the natural
sequence Rook to even
Pawn takes E3
nope white can't take it because of
Bishop two and six so King has to move
away but then we can play Bishop to G7
forcing yet another passive move
and the end result is this time around
we are getting two Pawn where white king
is completely misplaced
last but not least what happens if your
opponent continue here with Bishop to G3
well black choices are very obvious
Bishop to G7 attacking the Rogue Knight
to D4 looks the only logical response
but after Queen to B4 check Knight to D2
and the move H5
where black has a very simple threat to
nabbing this piece and it doesn't matter
however white responds whether H3 or F3
let's say in my recent game my 2000
rated opponent continue with H3
saving the bishop but actually losing
the game
how well now comes a very simple
sequence Knight takes G3 Pawn takes G3
completely destroying the white Pawn
structure and on top of everything we
have this queen to C3 attacking on E3 so
that white has to play this pity move
King to F2 whereupon after the following
sequence Bishop takes D4 Pawn takes D4
Queen takes D4 King to even
Queen check
and at the end black gobble up yet
another pawn and come out as a complete
dominating position
in fact in my game my opponent really
get frustrated and he continued with
Queen to E2
and after this chat
he should have moved the king but Queen
to F2 has been played
which is a big time disaster as Queen to
E5 nabbed The Rook in the corner
the second move I want to consider is D
capture C5 and I think this is probably
the easiest one as black and plain
Knight to A6 not only regaining the pawn
back but get a very good position just
within the opening stage
kindly note that Queen to D4 doesn't
stop us as Queen to A5 and indeed black
get the pawn back
so a sample line can goes like this
E3
black get the pawn back and now very
simple plan you go ahead with the dragon
structure where just like Sicilian the
half open C file gives black enough
counter play in the game
for example let's see a common piece
layout Knight to F3
D6 there is no point of playing C3 now
so white should play Knight to C3
where yup G6 Bishop to C4 Bishop to G7
and when both the side castle look at
this position guys not only this D6 Pawn
has restrict white major pieces but once
we move the bishop out and put our major
artillery on the C file I think it is
only black who can have a lot of fun in
this line
and that is the reason why this line has
not been chosen by the good players and
as per the current engine analysis it
already gives black a comfortable
advantage
the third move I want to consider is D5
and I think this is the one move which
stops me earlier to play this line
because I don't play Banco and benoni
and this put me off to play this line
however to my surprise when I done some
extensive analysis I found out that you
don't need to know those lines as black
has some surprising idea starting with
Queen to B6
okay white has few choices and amongst
them he cannot play Queen to C1 as the
D5 Pawn drops
Knight to C3 enters into the main line
however you need to know why white can't
play B3 here as it looks very logical
well the simple answer is this chat wins
The Pawn on the spot
we have a forcing sequence here Bishop
to D2
Queen to D4
Knight to C3 is forced but then we can
chop on D5
and not only black come up with a clear
Pawn Advantage but the big tactical
point is when white plays Knight to B5
looks like a very good move we can
calmly play Queen to E4 and meeting the
move C4 with this counter-attacking move
A6
where the end result is completely fine
for the black
you can go through the sample line from
the PGN where I have shown that
even after the base sequence black
opening Pawn Advantage cannot be denied
so that is how you should play against
the move B3
here
well now let's look at the main line
Knight to C3
and to my surprise all the books and
videos has only considered the move
Queen captures B2 whereupon Bishop to D2
and white get some initiative later on
in the middle game with E4 and F4
but why bother about all these things
where black can play this very tricky
move
E6
and I think after this what is in a
trouble
how let's check out
there are two major choices here and
amongst them E4 has been highestly
played but I'm afraid here black can
unleash this tactical sacrifice
just look at this guys Knight takes E4
what to move
well the big tactical point is after
Knight takes E4 black has this little
check
and it doesn't matter however white
plays
he has to give the piece back
for example one Grand Master games
continue here with Knight to C3 but
after simple Queen captures F4
black obtained the whole pawn and the
bishop pair and easily converted the
full point
so nope Knight to C3 is a bad idea
the most accurate sequence here goes as
follow
Queen to D2
Queen captures E4 and now Knight to E2
which sets up a small trap that if you
take on D5 with the queen then after the
queen exchange white can play Knight to
C3 and even though white is a pawn down
this positions clearly favors the word
so I'm certainly not going to recommend
that line
and instead of this I recommend this
straightforward approach starting with
D6
well of course it gives the pawn back
after the following sequence
Pawn takes E6 Queen takes E6
and now white can't Castle here because
the A2 Pawn drops but what he can do is
play the move Rook to D1 and get his
Pawn back
okay no issues we can play Knight to C6
allowing white to take the pawn back
but the end result Queen captures A2
and although it looks scary for a moment
as our King is stuck in the center
technically this position is so good for
the black
let me show you how as one of my recent
game against a 2200 continue with Queen
capture C5
I took a yacht under the pawn
and in the game my opponent played
Knight to D4 which turned out as a big
time disaster because black has a simple
reputation
Queen to B4
exchanging the queen
and after C3 Knight to C6 Knight Tech C6
and pawn Tech C6
you can clearly see the downside of the
whole transaction
black has an outright parser on the a
file
and with some careful play I indeed
managed to get the full point
so no Knight to D4 is a bad idea by the
white here
so how about C3 eliminating this check
well it has another downside namely
Queen to B6
if the queen exchange then black
position is obviously better
so white should play Queen to D6
stopping Black to Castle
however just one move Bishop to E6
and you can easily see Rook to d8 is
coming up
and considering the engine Evolution it
is already giving a winning advantage to
the black
apart from Rook to D1 what can also try
here G3
but the following Grandmaster game gives
you a great illustration how to handle
such a scenario
black plays Knight to C6
Bishop to G2 and now very nice move
Knight to D4 stopping white to Castle
so white responded with Bishop to E3
blocking the E file
but the net result is after Knight takes
E2
quintix E2 Bishop to E7 and when both
the side Castle it is pretty obvious
that black emerged with a clear Pawn
advantage
the same story goes if your opponent
continue with d captures E6 because
after F takes E6
indeed black is threatening the move D5
and if white has to stop it he has to
play E4 which is again most popular
however it run into the same tactic
which we have seen earlier
yup Knight takes E4 Knight takes E4
Queen to B4 check
Queen to D2 Queen takes E4 Knight to E2
and Bishop to E7 gives black a
comfortable Pawn advantage
in fact there is a game in the database
where both the side Castle on the
opposite side and when white plays
Bishop to D6
black was more than happy to exchange
pieces
Bishop takes Queen takes
and then evacuate this queen with Queen
to C6 so that once she moved you can
easily play the move D5 and with the
space in the center an extra Pawn black
is clearly in the driver's seat